[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
大山学院大学の教授として
大約青学でレフリーをどうこそかなと
いうそういう話をさせていただきます
2015年
4月の25日
ネパールで大きな地震がありました
首都カトマンズの近く
規模がマグニチュード7.8
非常に大きなし
以外を広範囲にわたりぱる前記また中国
バングラディッシュ
周りの国々にも広がります
この大きな地震の後
実際に
8,500人以上の方が亡くなり
2万人以上の方が怪我をされました
このネパールのニュースをおそらく皆さん
テレビ塔で見ていたかと思います
今インターネットが普及しているので被害の様子が例えば写真で
方まずの様子あ
どんな形で現場で被害起きているのか
そういった情報がさまざまな形でやりとりされたと思う
例えばこういう
ドローンそうディザスターズというチーム
現場でドローンを飛ばして撮影した映像こちらです
実際に倒れた母の顔
もしくは街並みそういったものが
今自分たちの手でへ
封殺してい
それをインターネットを載せるということまでは
できないん
おいたものを見るとだいたいどんな被害なのかというと大まかにわかるかもしれないん
ですよ
実際にじゃあこれが非常にすぐ描けられるかという
この映像から場所を特定すると非常にまた難しい
もしくは様々な技術的な課題がまだ言われているん
いずれにしてもこういった技術そして web というものがありますので
こういったものを
被災者のためにどう使ったらいいのか
実際に今年の4月
この青山学院大学に新しい学部が出来ました
浦氏はこの4月
この青山学院の地球社会共生学部という
組織
に所属しました
ちなみに
ひき社会共生学のかということを知っているという方と京都ろぐらいいらっしゃいます
でしょうかあればいますよし
結構やっぱり青学ホームなるとあの名立めちゃでちゃってるんですねありがとうござい
ます
いずれにしても古橋は9もともと空間情報を専門にしておりますので
がっ生たちにはグローバル系の学部として世界でどこに行っても
もし地図がなくても自分たちのやるべき仕事をきちんと
成し遂げられるそういう空間情報のノウハウを
のか教えるこれがフラッシュの民主党になります
実際にネパールで地震が起きた時
僕は学生たち
このキーワードを使ってメールを送りました
crysis マッピングをやります
授業
としてではなくて融資になりますのでこの活動自体に参加しても対応
もらえないわけですでも
気持ちがあれば集まってくださいということを相模原キャンパス
プロバラーニングコモンズというスペースに
よしのメンバーが集まって
くらいスナッピングとなぜどうやってネパールの人達を
インターネット
と情報使ってサーポートできるのとということをレクチャーしました
実際にこれは我々の活動だけではなくて世界中の仲間が活動した時のログになります
横軸が時間軸になりますがまぁ28日ぐらい
3日後ぐらいをピークにしながら10 asia た活動が治っていくにしても約1
か月間このネパールの状況をひたすら地図に落とすという作業をしました
またどのぐらいのメンバーが集まったのかというと会いたいここに小さく書いてあるん
ですがこの時で468082
だいたい5000人くらいの
国際的な
世界中の仲間だ
ネパールの地図を一生懸命作りません
またその中で日本人のメンバーがだいたい20200m
青山学院のメンバーでだいたい20名ぐらいのメンバーでこの活動に参加したという
ことです
実際に
どういう傷作られたと思います
これがその
一つの例です方まず
地震が起きる前の僕ら地図作っていました
ただこのグランド中主要な道路がいい
僕らが5000人インターネットへ
ボランティア
方まずの地図を作ると数字つでこうなります
ほとんどすべての建物が入力終わりました
これはカトマンズだけではなくて
山岳地域特に二種の広がったエリアの細かな地集落の一つ一つの建物ほぼ全て描き切り
ました
またこの地図を単に作るだけじゃなくてこの情報がさまざまな機関
例えばネパール政府だとかネパール郡また国連だとか赤十字そういった組織に我々の
地図が配られます
そして
この地図の上にいま何が起きているのかということを情報として載せるくらいす
マッピングの中でもいいしねとレポートという形で
情報載せたりまた
これは
僕と知り合いでこの宇宙からネパールを見る
このうちを宇宙からネパールを見たときに
自身の結果大きなランドスライド
土砂災害が起きているということが分かりました
これはどこなのかということを打ちよっ
人工衛星から突き止めると場所が分かりますこの場所の情報を多くらのチーズに重ね
ました
床が崩れたのかということと重ねると僕らはボランティアの力でほぼすべての建物が
プロットはってました
浅野てみるとやはり人の住んでいるところは少し平らのところですので
土砂災害が起きてと過去に起きてた場所になります
実際に発見した場所のいくつかはこのように小集落丸ごと飲み込んでしまったであろう
というそういう情報が地図を重ね合わせることによって分かります
こういう活動くらい数なってぃんぐという骨度そのものを世界中の仲間とを行いながら
今学生たちに指導しているというのが得る橋のミッションになる
もともとこの活動を始めたの実は
この青山学院大学に来る前今から5年前になりますが2010年の時
場所ははいっ
実際に
愛知のポルトープランス後首都直下でやはり2010年地震が起きました
1月12日です
その後
僕らは気付いたんです
愛知の地図ってあるのか
調べてみると全然なかった
そして今白く光ってますがそのことに気づいた
我々仲間がじゃあつくろうということで
誰かがどこかの道路を書いた瞬間今白く光っ建物を描いた旬果
また港も壊れてますので港の様子あ
潤で光ってるは避難所になり
こういう情報瞬時にインターネットを使ってボランティアでベースで作るということを
僕は5年前にこのハイチの地震の時に学びました
結果どうなったか先ほどと同じです僕らの地図はスカスカな状態です
ボランティアでーすべみんなで作っていたんですがとても細かな中ではありませんでし
たが
実際に地震が起きると数日間でこうなりました
非常に詳細が地図が
ボランティアの力でこの時でだいたい1000人ぐらい来ません
できるんだということを
避難所も実際に地震が起きた後の宇宙からの撮影されたデータもしくは
ドローンから撮影された画像を元に僕らはこの避難所に何人くらいの人が避難している
のかいう情報を加えて国連に報告したり
席中に報告することによって
適切な
食料だと改良品配分等が行われるベースの情報になります
いずれにしてもこのようなチーズのプラットフォーム僕らはオープンストリートマップ
と呼ばれる
2004年にイギリス人が始めた仕組みを採用していますがこの子図を作る
仲間と一緒に今活動してい
ちょうど僕らが活動を始めたときは2008年
今日のメンバーがこの活動に調印ん
[音楽]
ブーブー様々な家
ブーバーしかーしいいよあれよ
入学100整理されてなかったところが今ボランティアです
ほとんどの方が更新からする
中指なので少し
いずれにしてもこのような活動
親ばかん學院
相模原キャンパスを舞台にしながら
学生で日に教えてよ
ただ授業で教えるのではなくてやはりそのコミュニティを作らなければならないという
ことでこういったクライスマッターの育成というものに今
取り組んでいます
実際に授業だけではなくてそのコミュニティ組織としてこれから活動していくくらい砂
パジャパンという組織を今立ち上げているんですが
もう一つ
売れクリーしたいなと
さっきちょっと出てきません
本当はここでとばそうだなと思ったんですがさすがにやめました
ん
ただ事業でたらあの飛ばしたりしますあの想像するのは多分皆さんおもちゃに売ってる
声ドローン
ただニュースでも話題になっている通りで今あまり良いイメージを持たれてないです
本当にドローンて危険なものでしょ
こういった場でとば自由に飛ばしてもいいもの
なんじゃないかな
細胞が使ってるどのがこういうタイプですご期待
4枚羽根とか6枚ば姉というものではなくて飛行機タイプですか
300万します
初めて買いました
でもこれがあると全然違う細かい話は時間ないですがこれを使って例えばこれ福島で
撮影しました
飯田てだとかとみおかなとか人が住んでなエリアが今どうなっているのかということを
空から撮影してそれを地図に落とすということを僕らと正解上の仲間とこれはアメリカ
のメンバーですけども
手伝ってもらいながら
撮影した者情報もとに地図を作っていくということを福島でも世界中でも行って
またやっぱり300の高いですので飛ばすためにちょっと不安になります
今僕の手作りで同じようなものを10枚でフクロウというこれ3号機です
そういうプロジェクトをやっていただくと思った情報と斜めから撮ったものを真上から
見るように変換したいというの処理
そういったような処理をするツールを作ったりもしくは撮影した
航空写真ドローンで撮影した写真をどうやってみんなで共有するかということを
ツールとして開発していたりしますこれはフィリピンの2013年の台風廃案
の時の被害をの様子をドローンで撮影してその写真をみんなに共有するための仕組みで
今サンプルとして入っていますが
これは今進めています
いずれにしてもドローンというものは
使い方によって危険なものにもなります
でもどこかの会社が輝くかけているようなスロー
そういったものを
マネるわけじゃないですけども使う側の問題になります
逆に使わなければ正しい使い方というものをきちんと学べば
ドローンだってすごく強い時になるん
そこをどう実現するのか
ということを今我々のクラスマッピングの中では真剣に考えています
一番大きな問題なんだと思います
最近様子なんです
練習する場所じゃないんです
本当に
ここ何年間かずーっと事故もなく飛ばしていた場所が今年申請したら会えなく許可され
ない
そういう事態にはなっています
僕らはどうやったら自分たちの武器を
磨けるのか
どうやったら自分たちのドローン
操縦する使いこなすテクニックを学べるのかという場所
やっぱり作っていかないとダメだなということには感じてい
実際に今年の11月7日にスタートするんですが
存分にドローンを飛ばせられる場所を用意しています
follow インパクトチャレンジというイベントを今年から始めることにしました
実際に国がしやるのではなく企業がやるのではなく
一般市民がコミュニティとしてドローンを練習する場所を
きちんと
設置したいと思っています
実際にこれはテストですねと走る雰囲気です
今のところで小型ドローン手作りです
それを飛ばしながらスピードだとかわざと
いろんなものを競い合うちょうど生井1回でしてますけども
落ちましたが
まあこういった情報をみんなで共有する場を作りたいなと思っています
もちろん操縦だけではなくてそれがどう
災害人役に立つのう
もしくはどう地図作りに行かせるのかということを考えながら
プライスナッパ
ドローンを支えるコミュニティーをどうやって育て位
ここが今一番の大きな課題かなと思っています
最後に
こそ実
2巻とトークで大きな災害雨水がいなくています
これは国土地理院ドローンのチームが実際に
北館ともエリアで
日野川の方で撮影したドローン6封殺が部になりますがこういう情報がもう国でも
当たり前に飛ばせられます皆さんも飛ばせられますルールさえ守って
薬のことに使わなければドローンは非常に強い武器に
そして今日の朝の段階ですが今どこでどう浸水しているのかという情報もオープンする
マップの中にはもう反映されています
僕がやりますただ情報はいただいてやってい
こういうことが今技術的に可能になっているということをぜひ知っていただきたい
またこれにあなたも本当に今日から参加可能です
ぜひ
一緒に
やりませんそして
これネタかぶりました先ほど等
僕らは日本人勢1億人をし頭を作れる
仲間マッパにしたいなと思っています今日もこの t シャツいつも来ていますが一応
いく相違農家という言葉を掲げながら
自分の持ってる少しの時間でいいんです持っている情報をみんなに共有するそれが一つ
地図を作る元になる
そういった意味で日本人全員を伊能忠敬にしたいということを考えていますし
うちの娘達ですもう
ネパールの時朝起きてんこういう状態ですネパールの地図作るよということで8歳の娘
と4相当に3歳の娘と1歳の長男はお茶飲んでるだけですけど
釣りにしても
小さな子どもでも今参加できるそういう意味で
繰り返しになりますがぜひあなたを待ったになりませんか
どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]